( intro music )
Jer Thorp: What we are trying
to do with this expedition
is to produce threads
that can lead from
this untouched wilderness
out into the public.
And those threads can
be grasped by anybody,
anybody who wants to find a
connection to this place.
( applause )
Steve: Visible from space the
Okavango Delta was voted in as
our planet's 1000th UNESCO World
Heritage Site in June last year.
Now this was a long
overdue accolade for
a wilderness beyond comparison.
The jewel of the Kalahari.
Every year we
haul ourselves across
the Okavango Delta in
Northern Botswana.
These 350 kilometer,
18 day expeditions
take us across a
living wilderness.
It is considered to be the most
valuable wetland on our planet.
The most valuable
protected wetland.
The Okavango Delta is home to
the largest remaining population
of elephants on our planet.
The native population there
is around 150,000 elephant.
That's over half
of the elephants
remaining on the
African continent.
We lose 100 elephants
every single day
on the continent.
That's every 15 minutes an
elephant is shot for its ivory.
The lions. Over 2000 lions are
found in the Okavango Delta.
Many people don't know it but
we are more likely to lose lions
in Africa than elephants.
This is the super pride,
this is the Matata pride
means problem animals.
That is Bob Marley
on the side there,
he's got a dreadlock
coming out of his chin,
great Sphinx of a lion.
Him and his four brothers
rule the largest pride
in the Okavango
and I know them well.
The Kalahari leopard. It's the
largest leopard in Africa.
Keystone populations of hyena.
Rhino find sanctuary
in the Okavango Delta.
Buffalo, the great herds
still exist there.
Fifty thousand buffalo
in that system.
Cheetah, wild dog...
If we lose this system
in its current state,
the Okavango Delta
and its catchment,
we will lose these
species in that region.
And that is their heartland.
It is our call to action to
look north to the source
into the catchment in Angola,
a country that
has remained closed
to us for many, many years.
Thirty years of civil war were
fought up in that catchment.
We are taking four Ba'yei
river Bushmen with us,
to go down that river.
That's going to happen
in two months' time.
Now this is in Angola.
Angola is
a unique country in
Southern Africa.
It is now the second
largest oil producer.
It is booming between seven
and 22 percent growth rate,
every single year.
This is the skyline of Luanda.
Five years ago there was not
one tall building in Luanda.
Now there are many.
Now you look here into the
catchment and you wonder why
it has remained untouched.
It has remained the largest
undeveloped river catchment
on Earth.
The only river that is
longer without dams
is the Yukon in Canada.
The largest land battles in
Africa since World War Two
were fought in this catchment.
The densest minefields,
land minefields in Africa
are in this catchment.
This is one of the remotest
places in Southern Africa.
This is the source
of the Okavango.
This is where we are going to
launch our expedition from.
Now, two years ago
we identified this site,
there was no signs of roads,
there was no signs of any
kind of deforestation.
This has happened since then,
it's happening every single day.
Angola is being torn apart,
the clock is ticking.
We have two or three years to
achieve what we want to achieve.
That is new national
parks, game reserves
wildlife management
areas, wildlife corridors,
all the way up that river.
We are working with the
Governor of that province
who really wants
to see this happen.
He is one of the most
powerful people in Angola
and is going to drive
this process for us.
There is hope.
This is Khobono Mank'etu.
He is my friend and mentor.
He is a Ba'yei river bushman.
The Ba'yei arrived in the late
1700's into the Okavango Delta
with a revolutionary
new technology.
The mokoro, an 18-foot dug out
canoe that would forever change
our human experience in
that remote wilderness.
It was the first time that
human beings actually accessed
the central wilderness
was these guys.
So, the Ba'yei have taught us to
pull ourselves safely in these
channels, to avoid the wildlife
to drink the waters
of the Okavango.
The mother Okavango that
gives them everything.
From the day we start
to the day we end
you can drink it any
time from the water.
That is how pure
this system is.
We harvest fish, smoke it
in the traditional way.
We live off water lilies,
the rhizomes and the seeds
and the pollinated flowers.
We listen to the swororo.
That is the music
of that wilderness.
They teach you how to interact
with the animals.
This is an elephant,
I'm just saying
"I'm unarmed, I'm not
big, I'm just unarmed
I'm holding nothing
and I'm passing."
To avoid the hippos.
It's a grumpy animal,
very much misunderstood.
But if you give them the space,
they're not going to harm you.
Crocodiles, now
you have these...
sometimes the water is
murky, sometimes it's clear.
You often see them under you.
This is probably a
three meter crocodile.
This one here is a
15 foot Nile crocodile.
It's about 20 yards
ahead of us.
I'm putting pressure
on it to try and move it
down the channel.
It's feeling claustrophobic,
it now thinks that
we're another crocodile
so it's wheeling around at us.
"It's coming around,
it's coming around."
Now I can tell you your heart
is pumping as this is happening.
There is nothing I can
do to avoid this animal
so I've pulled off to the side
I've told the television
presenter in the front
to hold the paddle, just I meant
for him to barricade himself
he ended up hitting the animal.
Look at this approach.
( man screaming )
But that's the reality
of this place.
You're not in control
of anything around you.
You have to surrender
yourself to probability,
surrender yourself
to the wilderness.
Now it was in 2012, the
last day of that expedition
coming down the main
channel, the Boro,
fifty kilometers in one day,
pulling as hard as we can.
And to be honest all I
was thinking about was
"burger and beer,
burger and a beer."
( audience laughter )
After 18 days of eating
water lilies and fish.
There were two Swana kids
on the bank
and they shouted out to us...
"Lakuah, lakuah, lakuah."
That means
white people, foreigners.
The oldest Ba'yei with us
Mr. K'etu-k'etu,
father of Khobono Mank'etu,
my friend and mentor,
he shouted back at those,
those kids on the bank.
He said,
"Hauna makua, Ba'yei hei'lah"
which means there are no
foreigners here, only Ba'yei.
It is something that I wanted
to hear my entire life
to be considered as
something or someone that was
good for that wilderness,
for the mother Okavango.
But as Ba'yei we enter that
wilderness barefoot, unarmed
with minimal food rations
and very few possessions.
But as digital Bushmen.
In this new age of
exploration we come with
hundreds of pounds of
batteries and solar panels
tablet computers, cameras, all
the paraphernalia of technology
we need to share these
experiences with the world.
To do the science we need to do,
to measure impacts in the future
to understand exactly the
way this wilderness is now
before it is disturbed by
developments upstream.
And they are coming, we're
seeing it every day in Angola.
This is the magic of
National Geographic...
the Explorer program.
I was fortunate enough
to meet these three men
Jer, who is going
to be speaking now,
Gregg Treinish in the back
and Shah Selbe.
They are going to change the
future of the Okavango Delta
and the river that supplies
it for future generations.
It is a powerful thing that
came about because of this.
Now Jer has taken us from
live blogging to
live data expeditions.
What you're seeing here is all
of us in the central wilderness.
You've got Jer is there,
Chris, Steve and GB.
We are on an island,
we're just about to leave.
It's eight o'clock and
we're on the channel.
What you're seeing popping up
around us are what we're seeing.
There is a short delay
in our satellite link
but this is literally in real
time, that's real people,
us in a remote wilderness
trying to affect change,
trying to explore it.
Photographs will pop up and
this system advances
every single year.
We're very excited to see
what Jer achieves this year
when he joins us.
Shah took us from little
strips and pieces of paper
writing down the water
quality as we go down
to environmental
sensor platforms.
Solar powered that can sit
out there autonomously
and send via cellular,
via satellite, via Wi-Fi,
a whole bunch of parameters
of water quality.
We're gonna expand that network
to hundreds of these platforms
throughout the Okavango Delta.
As Shah puts it we're gonna be
measuring the literal heartbeat
of that wilderness in real time
for the world to see.
The whole world will be privy
to the impacts when they come.
And we'll explain that to people
as it... as it arrives.
Gregg. Gregg is
trying to figure out
how to bring life
to this network.
We need people to
connect the dots.
So, he's looking at ways of
safely getting volunteers
in there, to go and
maintain these platforms
as we see them go down.
We are talking about
elephants and hippos
and things trudging over them.
That kind of thing is gonna
happen and we're gonna need
Gregg's volunteers
to help us with that.
We did a Hangout
in the last expedition.
We arrived literally 20 minutes
before we went live.
This is one of the
remotest locations
but a wonderful
experience and on cue,
an elephant walked directly
behind us at the end of it.
It was about the third last
day of the expedition.
We were at Eagle Island and
I got past this,
this big, grumpy old hippo.
He goes under the reeds,
I pull off and
another guy is quite far behind,
Jer is with him.
And this angry hippo comes,
like two more angry hippos,
now there's three of them,
I am watching this go on
and these things, literally
tusks out in front of Jer
slapping those
go under his mokoro
I turn around to
pull away from this
'cause I don't want
to get into trouble.
In my mind I see Jer just being
enveloped by a wave of hippo.
Something like that
but he captured
that in the data.
He is able to share
that through the data.
And I'm excited
to see that now.
( applause )